and never look
back hacks and simply learn to get ahead
Jess Danish a civil engineer turned data
scientist who decided to Simply learn
what with a course from a premier
[Music]
University true champion who upskilled
to win
big how big a massive hike that
transformed my life
Danish changed gears pretty early in the
race but pron wanted to explore more to
get ahead simply learn from mechanical
engineering to a data analyst and a
podcaster in his free time career
transformation bro simply learn
expert dat
expert with a well structured course it
felt like a piece of cake that is simply
awesome what's also awesome is that long
didn't choose a quick fix he just added
data science into the
mix Nan how did you change the game
worked on real industry problems to
become the real deal a joint family a
regular job responsibilities but nothing
could stop Nan from getting ahead what
an allrounder de Hoya night with
flexible learning you can always make it
right bashing your
situation you two will find your way to
get ahead when you simply learn
short simply learn get ahead with simply
[Music]
learn
recording in
progress
hi everyone uh welcome to the program
preview of advanced AI program and
business decision making by Waton uh and
we'll be starting this session in few
minutes meanwhile I can see a lot of
introductions coming in on chat here so
I am Rasha Khan I'm your host for
today's webinar and I'm joining all the
way from Bangalore India and I'm
thrilled to be your host today uh drop
us a hello and let us know where are you
tuning in from and let the global
conversations begin I can see a lot of
introductions coming in on chart here
and I can see folks have joined from
Poland Ka and I can see Netherland Sri
Lanka I can see lakman has joined from
Andra Pradesh I can see Hector has
joined from Las Vegas so welcome
everyone good morning good afternoon
good evening wherever you're joining us
from this is a global webinar and before
we start please do let us know on chat
here introduction your name and where
are you joining us from it's good to
network right these events right it's
good to network with folks on the chart
here so uh and also we would love to
know your thoughts even during the
session as well if you have any insights
if you have any questions you can let us
know in the cu& box so just a quick tip
before we start and uh meanwhile I can
see a lot of introductions coming in on
CH chart here that's
great awesome we'll be starting the
session in few few minutes meanwhile
let's go to the ground rules here so uh
we have very simple ground rules here so
if you have any question for the speaker
who are already here with us you can put
down that question in the Q&A box uh as
you can see that we get a lot of
messages on chat here it'll be hard for
us to track your question here and we
would love to answer all of your queries
here uh so please go and put on your
question to the Q&A box if you have any
questions related to the program in
general to the career in general in AI
so uh and also there will be special
duration for the Q&A part so you don't
have to worry your questions will be
answered in that uh basically particular
duration in case we're not able to take
up during the session
and uh the session has been recorded so
in case you want to go through the
recording of the session again you can
expect a followup email with recording
link and also the bonus offer for
attending the session for the program
which we have we'll be talking about
that pretty soon also to request a proof
of attendance for this webinar you can
provide your name in the post webinar
survey which you'll be getting uh after
the session uh and in order to get the
webinar certificate you need to
basically stay till the end of the
session so thank you so much once again
I'm I can see the introductions are
still G coming
in and uh we will be basically starting
the session in few minutes meanwhile uh
before we start let's get to know each
other a little better so uh before we
start we would love to know that how
many years of experience do you
currently have so you can see four quick
options in the poll here this is a
single Choice question you can select
one option which is the most suitable
for you so I'll just read out those
options for you
here so so the first one is you if you
have less than two years of experience
you can uh basically take uh that option
and if you have two to five years of
experience you can select the second
option if you have five to 10 years of
experience you can select the third one
and also if you
have more than 10 user experience you
can select the fourth one and as I'm
speaking I can already see that Forks
have already started sharing their
experiences on the poll here so we will
be starting the session in few minutes
meanwhile we have a quick portfolio on
your screen so we would love to know how
many years of experience do you
currently have awesome as I was speaking
we basically were getting a lot of
messages in the Q&A box
already okay okay uh awesome awesome
[Music]
um okay I can see folks are replying on
chat here as well so in case this
particular Bard does not cover your
experience you can let us know on chat
here here as well so that's not an issue
but uh if you actually is uh if you can
see the most suitable option for you
here you can also select in the poll as
well so I'll be closing the poll in 5
seconds because I can see most of the
folks have already shared the responses
in the poll here that's great we've
gotten a really really active audience
here so I'll just close the poll in five
seconds so 5 4 3 2 1 let me quickly end
the poll and also share the results with
you so as we can see that
40% of the folks who have joined us here
have less than two years of experience
and also equally 40% of the folks who
have joined us here have more than years
of experience so we have
gotten to 10 years and as we can see
that we have gotten three of the vs for
two to five years and also five to 10
years as well so thank you so much for
sharing that with us and uh I can still
see the introductions coming in so
that's great keep it coming and uh
meanwhile we move on we'll talk about
the agenda of the session so uh we will
be getting to know a little bit more
about you how we can help you better and
uh for that you can basically let us
know if you have any queries uh we
already have a speaker here with us who
will address all of your queries you
know as much as possible we'll be
talking about eii in business and we'll
be talking about what this program
offers you and we talking about how this
program gets your future ready and also
taking you through the enrollment steps
and as I have mentioned earlier that
there'll be a special duration for the
Q&A part so please don't worry about it
in case your questions are not answered
we'll be taking those towards the end so
please do put on your questions the Q&A
box and also keep it relevant to the
program and the basically toping of the
session so that's that's just a small
request that's all so moving on we
already have a speaker here with us Eric
hamburger Eric first of all welcome
welcome to the session and thank you so
much for taking the time out you know
for taking us to the program prview
uh so would you like to give us your
introduction to the crowd here sure
thank you
Rasha uh and thanks to all of you out
there for joining us today uh I'm sure
looking at the incredible Global
representation that we've had and I see
in the chat that it is a variety of
times for a variety of us right now um
in Southern New Jersey where I am it is
11:38 a.m. and yesterday and tomorrow I
will be on Wharton's campus as I am most
days of the week uh but today you catch
me at home also I'm looking at this head
shot of myself and realizing that uh for
the global audience you may not care but
uh in a few days time it is the uh
Halloween holiday in the United States
where folks dress up in costumes and I
am trying to get uh quite ready for my
costume which requires a beard that is
not particularly full and I will shave
it this weekend so a little bit of Grace
from our audience I appreciate it
sincerely um okay I
one I'm really impressed by the
representation that we have across the
globe here joining today and it's a a
real reminder about the global cohorts
that come to this program and also I
think an indication for all of you the
types of folks and the diversity of
experience that you'll get to interact
with and for any of you that have spoken
on an engagement you know usually
talking about yourself may be the less
favorite part of the program but as
Rashia said my name is Eric hamper and I
am the managing director of Warton
online and uh I help facilitate this
partnership with simply learn which
quite frankly allows us to take uh our
incredible faculty and thought
leadership in spaces like machine
learning and artificial intelligence to
a more Global audience and I think we've
already seen the evidence of that here
today with this audience profile now uh
prior to taking over Wharton online I
was the founding managing director of a
business called Wharton live and there
we were tasked with building and we
continue to build Dynamic synchronous
virtual programs both for small intimate
learning audiences and also for massive
cohorts at the turn of the calendar year
the school made a strategic decision to
merge that team with the larger Wharton
online team sort of uniting all of our
capabilities to do online education
which is to say we've been doing it for
a long time um and humbly I would say
we're we're getting pretty good at it
now prior to these roles uh I was the
assistant dean of graduate business at a
nearby School here in the Northeast
called Villanova University I've been an
adjunct faculty in MBA programs and
other graduate level courses and
departments for the past 15 years which
is making me feel a little old I've got
two boys they're eight and six and
um it's never dull is all of you that
are juggling many things your career
your family all your work life
obligations we know uh that we are quite
busy and the fact that you are taking
time out to continue your education and
consider this program I salute you all
right because if these things were easy
everyone would do it okay I think we can
move ahead as we talk about maybe a
little bit more of warten online down
the road in this presentation but as we
start to segue into ai's role and
driving the economy and sort of its role
in
business I think about um data driving
the economy I think I need to also
preface some of these cont um comments
to share with all of you while we have
eight incredible Wharton faculty and I
should mention that for Wharton online
and Executive Education here at the
Wharton School we only use standing
fully tenured faculty
members and that may not matter to you
um but for the Savvy enrol that has
looked at other programs at other
institutions other reputable
institutions included often you'll see
programs like this outsourc to an
adjunct or subject matter expert um it
is rare that you get the full research
faculty of a top arguably the top
business school in the world teaching in
this program and we don't just have one
of those we have eight uh I am not one
of them I just work with those folks to
make sure that they bring their thought
leadership to bear as Professor Ragu AAR
did this past Saturday and Professor Lyn
woo her herself will do this coming
Saturday and some of our Master Class
sessions that are a part of this program
so that's also to say while I know a
great deal about artificial intelligence
uh I am not the person that'll be
teaching you in this program that said I
I think we've been suggesting that you
know AI is such a fast-moving field that
organizations need to take a portfolio
approach to build capacity within their
organizations so we're using data and
structured forms and we're experimenting
with AI to analyze the unstructured data
right data that grows and accumulates
among our respective data houses 80% of
which I mean approximately speaking is
unstructured so AI enables us to mine
that data in search of the gold that is
essentially buried there right what are
we going to uncover what are we going to
learn and then how are we going to apply
those learnings these Technologies allow
us to do things like test
hypothesis of our business and also
manage uncertain environments like the
kinds of circumstances we find ourselves
in today right emerging from coid global
global conflicts as we know um and also
I saw we have a learner from Morocco
we've got natural disaster that's also
impacted several places so as we think
about our fellow folks that are going
through tough times AI is still going to
play a role there right fear of
recession there's so many other factors
that largely have sometimes we have
little to no control over and they still
in influence our deliberative processes
when it comes to decision making so
whatever we can do to bring data to
better test these hypotheses and the
decision-making options that sit before
us the better we will be and the more
successful our business will be as a
result so you know there's outfits like
there like McKenzie and TCS that have
created analyses that call for people
that stand between business models that
have been developed and leveraged by the
administrative leaders say in in or
around the SE Suite of a particular
organization and the data scientist so
this course in particular is something
that is not intended to be say
Engineering in Focus instead it's
providing business cases across multiple
fields and industries okay think broadly
about General management which in one
respect I would say is is why this
program has such blanket appeal at least
in my opinion that through the
exploration of both structured and
unstructured data you can literally
translate that through the the
information that's coming out of your
data warehouses into a forecast or a
decision-making model that helps inform
the decision-making process across
really multiple levels of management
right the management ecosystem that's
inside your organization so really if if
you think about where we are today in
contrast to where you will be at the
completion of this program picture
yourself is understanding enough about
Ai and machine learning technologies
that are currently
maturing rapidly before our eyes right
and apply that understanding and
Advising senior leadership at your
organization which might actually be
yourself okay to start to form questions
that this data can then answer it's
really that sort of mid to senior level
role that will analyze cases all right
we're going to analyze cases in this
program that cover companies at really
the Leading Edge of extracting critical
information from the loose data that's
available all right to them really
amongst vast repositories of what we
said before right unstructured data and
I should say that in that pool this pool
of unstructured data we're talking about
a number of different things right email
voicemail video Audio Web traffic data
so many other things in that inform
customer
profiles that reveal how they move from
sort of exploration as a customer to
ultimately purchasing a product all of
the data sources are frankly different
than when I was a young consumer say 20
years ago when we only had things like
tabular data think relational databases
and spreadsheets that were organized by
rows and columns and they were applied
in more direct ways right to predict and
drive forecasting models that were
frankly rooted in a world of far more
uncertainty and looking at the
professional experience that rash has
solicited before at the start of the
session I know a lot of You Are probably
in the same boat with remembering those
early days right so back then we did
things like what we did scenario
planning we did sensitivity analyses but
now we're talking about it in part in
this program optimization models right
that emerge with Clear Choices and
hopefully expected forecasts that we can
Bank on So In Those Old Days of Rel
relational database Management systems
and the various forms of structured data
I you know not to date myself and some
of our Global Learners might not care
this isn't your father's old mobile
anymore right this is a new day where
we're all going to know employers and
top level leaders have an
expectation I mean dare I say demand
really right that top people understand
these Technologies and are able to
leverage their full capabilities okay so
these new tools are allowing us to mine
this unstructured data in productive
ways and I think that's another
fundamental Cornerstone of this course
of this program so I think that really
talks to uh the next slide too Rasha
about how it's impacting every aspect of
business you know this course is going
to show you a bunch of
examples that come from organizations
that have ex successfully applied
artificial intelligence and machine
learning Technologies to develop new say
sales and marketing strategies as one
example we'll be looking at the work
that's been done by modern marketing
firms to develop personalized
recommendation engines and explore other
marketing strategies that are informed
by large
transactional and analytical databases
that are therefore informed by large
pools of customer behavior that augment
our data points you'll be looking at
large Financial applications like
Midstream identification of patterns of
customer behavior and that suggests
fraudulent activity perhaps for
companies that are processing things
like eCommerce uh transactions I know
that's been a situation that we've dealt
with in the past this enables I really
think the the potential for intervention
right you can actually do something
about it to take steps to assure the
security of something like transactional
security for transactions that might
initially appear
suspicious we can call on our incredible
faculty associated with Wharton's people
analytics initiative their conference
was back in person a couple months ago
right here in downtown Philadelphia uh
and it examined how artificial
intelligence and machine learning can be
used to successfully navigate the
tasks uh that inform our decision-
making say on things like hiring your
decisions on promotion your decisions on
Performance Management AI can play a
strong role here but let's remember
there are also ethical considerations
when it comes to the management of
people and that critical aspect is not
overlooked here and it's one I hope that
we all take very seriously we've got our
particular Professor right now in this
program Kevin War that's developing a
program in AI ethics right now and he's
also one of the people that does master
classes in this program right there's a
lot of different threads we can pull
given the thought leadership from the
Wharton School that's part of this
program uh I know one particular case
we've looked at is zes money a fintech
firm um that's been a part of this
before we've got you know G20 countries
even here in the United States people
that lack FICO scores they can't qualify
for loans and things like that
exacerbate the division between the
people that have
and the people that don't okay that can
perpetuate itself generationally and I
don't think that's just unique to the
United States could we not apply new
fintech technologies that really better
underwrite the eligibility of the people
who are indeed creditworthy but maybe
aren't seen so Through The Eyes of
outdated Legacy systems and
applications um it's a really
interesting thing that can help maybe
more democratize financial institutions
and people who have access to Capital so
okay I think we could skip ahead
one me talk about well-rounded
understanding real quick we'll be
getting the questions in a moment so um
preparing
yourself preparing yourself for really
what is dare I say new I still think
it's new because it's Dynamic and S
changing but this new decision-making
Arena this program helps people like
you're
gain the kind of like tactile experience
exposure to the terminology the Gomen
clature so to speak that the engineers
and the data scientists use in building
and developing artificial intelligence
and machine learning projects in perhaps
the company you work for or the company
in which you aspire to work for in the
future it also these this program and
this curriculum is going to enable you
to level set with an understanding of
these things these Technologies okay
what constitutes Big Data what
constitutes artificial intelligence what
is machine learning how is it conceived
relative to company size what is it mean
for a small firm and how they might
pursue outsourced Solutions on the open
market what about a big firm and their
application Development Group coming out
of the program you should understand the
fundamental differences between
supervised and unsupervised deep
learning you're going to explore cases
that touch on those types and the Deep
learning the kind of algorithmic based
processes are put in play by development
organizations for example so if we if we
actually swing back to people management
and legitimate ethical concerns over say
HR applications there are really Myriad
of corporate organizational risks that
can be associated with artificial
intelligence you've either seen them
firsthand in your place of business or
with a competitor or you've certainly
read about it in the news algorithms
have the unfortunate potential of being
just as biased as we can be as
individuals when it comes to things like
hiring things like promotion performance
assessment this program is going to
compel you to take a step back and to
realize you know there's ways in which
AI applications can Implement and spread
bias in an undetected way or it can be
in some circumstances less than
transparent and processes that utilize
various data points to inform an
algorithm to make a particular
recommendation it's supposed to inform
the decisions we make right these are in
my estimation critically important
issues for General management and this
is perhaps even more critical for those
working in the nonprofit and the
government sectors I'm sure there's a
few of you out there today okay all
right I think we can push ahead one more
so we keep working our way through
through some regular remark I think this
is an important question yes you know
have you been
looking yeah Raj take this one for us
sure uh so uh basically we have talked
about you know the how AI is involving
in business today so uh what's stopping
you from Gaining the AI expertise you
can see four quick options on your
screen here uh this is a multiple choice
question so you can select multiple
options here uh so what is the biggest
challenge here when it comes to gaining
AI expertise so I'll just read out those
options for you uh the first one is I
can't find a program with a fully
comprehensive curriculum second one I
don't have the Practical exposure I need
to become job ready third one I find it
difficult to learn from pre-recorded
videos and the fourth one my work
schedule won't allow me enough time for
learning so while I was speaking in
folks I've already started sharing the
response of the poll here that's great
we have gotten a really active audience
here active set of aspiring Learners
here as well so uh I'll give 10 seconds
more for the poll here uh meanwhile uh I
can see there are many interesting
questions coming in the Q&A part of the
session and we'll be taking those pretty
soon in sometime meanwhile keep the
questions coming in if you have already
voted for the poll here so I'll give 10
seconds more for the poll
here
okay I can see most of the folks have
already shared the responses for the
poll here so I'll just just give five
seconds more so 5 4 3 2 1 I'll be ending
the poll now and also sharing what is
the biggest concern here let's see what
have folks shared with us over this poll
so as we can see the biggest concern
here is you have gotten 50% of the votes
for I wouldn't get the Practical
exposure I need to become job ready and
45% of the folks have also shared that I
can't find a program with a fully
comprehensive curriculum and uh 35% of
the folks have shared that my work
schedule won't allow me enough time for
Learning and few of the folks have also
voted for I find it difficult to learn
from pre-recorded video so thank you so
much sharing that with us uh meanwhile
let's Mo move on to the program preview
here so the Waton online program preview
for EI for decision decision making
business strategies and application
comes with comprehensive curriculum with
an industry online learning path and
also uh it gives you online live
discussion supplements self-based
learning uh it gives you access to
integrated assignments quizzes for
practical learning and also this program
will be flexible to fit your lifestyle
and schedule in case you are working
professional which we saw a lot of them
in you know when we took the experience
uh the program duration for this one is
three months and you can just complete
it by giving three to five hours per
week um Eric just had a question about
the program here so in the Life Learning
environment how does the peer and instru
interaction looks like can you tell us a
little bit about
that sure um and and you know if if it's
striking me now rash if we want to go
ahead um a couple slides we could also
highlight some of the faculty um and
then pivot back to this if it's
applicable the so one I want to thank
everybody out there for answering that
most recent poll um you know there's
challenges here when you're talking
about a program that's covering subject
matter that changes every
day right I mean we read about in the
news cycle last week you know the
potential acquisition of open AI for $80
billion um these things are changing
constantly which is exciting and I think
it's why it's critically important that
you consider a program that has live
sessions
and even better if those live sessions
are going to be hosted by folks like
those you see before you uh part of um I
mean to answer rash's question and and
really the question from our audience is
the The Faculty
deliver a master class for roughly two
hours in
length and we try to host these one time
per month and we rotate these faculty in
on a particular Cadence now the
interesting thing is
we actually have uh back-to-back weekly
sessions this particular week which is
nice when we have the opportunity to
offer more we absolutely do that so you
can Bank on one per month but it's a
possibility that you'll get more than
that so you see Professor ly woo she's
going to be teaching this Saturday um
you know I I always appreciate when she
she can start talking about deep fakes
she can show you some examples of which
she won't be able to tell she's going to
apply her research Professor Ragu irar
at the bottom right there taught this
past Saturday he is a marketing expert
uh and he can start to shed light on
some of the verticals covering marketing
and artificial intelligence that rash
had just kind of skipped over that we'll
return to in just a moment um but you
get the chance to not just hear from
these faculty for two hours but you get
to engage with them you can enter
questions into a chat you could try to
speak via microphone so I I I think that
that sort of access to the thought
leadership of Wharton faculty that are
experts they are the experts that are
writing the books and giving the
interviews and informing the research
and the business decisions that are
impacted by artificial intelligence
right here in this program now a quick
aside for me uh I have uh some of our
team right now down in Orlando Florida
for a huge HR
conference um we're talking like 4,000
attendees and these are chro Level
leaders the heads of leadership um
Talent Development L &d at their
particular corporations Fortune 500s and
we brought professor Matthew Bidwell
down to give a speaking engagement he's
down there next to Prof Professor iar
here on the screen a management
professor professor Bidwell um was
speaking in a theater session for which
uh we had a 100 seats and it felt like
um we were with a movie star or a rock
star because uh rather than a hundred we
had I I think over 600 people trying to
attend a thousand that had registered
because they are hungry for this sort of
Wharton thought leadership in subjects
like artificial intelligence and Human
Resources so that was really exciting
for us I think he was a little bit
overwhelmed about the interest in his
program uh but it's just sort of an
indicator that while all of those Folks
at a conference in Orlando Florida
yesterday were sort of like pushing and
shoving trying to get their way to this
sort of information you're going to get
it from the comfort of your home at some
point in this program okay so you can
relax you don't have to fight with
anybody to get a seat you're GNA be
there and you're going to get a chance
to interact directly and I think that's
pretty uh I think that's a lot of fun
okay so that was a little bit about the
interaction for that question rasher we
can come back to this one too to talk
about faculty a little bit more
later so let me just quickly go back to
the slide here uh so at the end of it
all you get the Wen online certification
which you can see here on the screen
uh for the AI for decision- making
business strategies and applications
program and also you get to work on real
world business case studies which we'll
be talking about in the upcoming slides
here and also the live online master
classes on water which Eric has already
mentioned uh and also a curriculum
co-created by eight distinguished water
professors which we have already talked
about uh also let's talk about the W
Advantage here so can you tell us a
little bit about
this sure and just quickly scanning chat
real time Rasha Cedric to your your
question yes and I I think chat GPT is
about to release plat 4.0 um or chat
gp4 uh really right about like next week
um some of our professors have already
gotten early access to that platform to
figure out how to leverage it for its
new advantages um Dennis your question
about having an AI degree unnecessary
and I think this is probably a question
that applies to a lot of folks out there
I don't want anybody to feel intimidated
if you don't have Quant background or
particularly strong in coding and math
that's frankly not what this program is
about this program is about level
setting and understanding of artificial
intelligence and machine learning as it
impacts business across various sectors
and verticals okay so you could consider
yourself managing a team that might have
that sort of expertise on board but you
need to understand it more deeply so you
can speak the language one and to lead
that team to start to answer the sort of
strategic questions that are challenging
your business so I don't want anybody to
be deterred if you think you know well
I'm not a coder or I don't have an AI
degree okay I wouldn't be too worried
about that now to rash's last question
about the competitive advantage of the
Wharton School oh boy um we're the
world's first business
school first to do it I humbly would say
I I think we're the best uh we have more
faculty um than any other business
school in the world at last count I
think we're over
220 these folks are experts in the field
I think I've sort of alluded to it a
second ago they rate thebook not a book
uh that lead research in the industry
their particular areas of expertise this
includes the eight people that have
content in this program and also teach
live uh you see sort of the the volume
of programs in addition won online
specifically in our team overseas 120
unique
programs but I think it's important for
all that scale we reach one to two
million people
annually that may not matter to you I
think what's important is we have one
program with simply learn and you
yourself are an individual right I think
that's what's important today what is
this program going to provide to you as
a singular individual no matter where
you're located um and that's one of the
reasons we partnered with simply learn
is to get to a global cohort that is
diverse in audience and professional
experience and can bring all of you
together in a singular learning
environment I think that's what's
important to me it's what's exciting
about a partnership like this and a
program like this uh so while we've
certainly got Global reach and a global
reputation I think about this more at
sort of a granular level for all of us
today awesome thank you so much for
sharing that with us Eric uh moving on
to the eligibility and prequisites here
so I think we have getting few questions
about the pr and eligibility here so uh
so here you don't have to have any prior
knowledge or experience in programming
and math and uh this is ideal for SE
suit Executives senior level managers
and Consultants so uh about the
eligibility part here uh so uh this
program does not require any knowledge
or experience in programming or
mathematics right so folks who are
coming from a non-programming or non-
mathematics background have you seen
those students succeed Eric uh when they
have taken up this
course yeah and and r quite plainly for
for that question it's actually the
majority of Learners that enroll in this
program fit that profile so don't feel
like you're you're the minority I think
you're actually going to find yourself
in in Good Company it can be
intimidating we all know right we can
all think back to uh primary school and
our challenges with mathematics for some
of us it comes easily for others it's
much harder um but I I think you're
you're going to be just fine I think
think about it in terms more of business
application thank you so much for
answering that also the ideal candidates
for this program as I mentioned uh you
can be a sees executive you can be a
senior executive Business Leaders and
managers and managers and leaders you
know who basically are seeking to build
their own capabilities in strategies
leadership and Innovation so how this
program prepares you we'll be talking
about more about that in the upcoming uh
slides here so uh as you can see H how
the program builds your uh skills uh
step by step so U Can you take us
through through foundations here of the
program basically how how it builds your
skill step by step through what in this
program sure I I think this this is
really kind of a A visual representation
of what we've been saying um throughout
the the presentation is that you know
we've got a diverse set of Faculty that
come from a variety of academic
departments here at the Wharton School
which shows the intentionality for which
this program has been built and also the
fact that none of these say right you're
going to be covering python in week
three three or right you're going to be
learning R in week five uh this is about
how all of these things touch in you get
foundations of platforms at the end um
but we're going through with Professor
Bidwell and Professor Peter Capelli
about human resource management um we've
got Finance faculty and from people like
Professor Michael
Roberts uh economics and government like
we we've already taken a look at
marketing and professor iar professor
Kevin warbach who oversees another
academic Department here so you're
getting Department chairs on top of this
these These are really I mean for lack
of a better phrase some Heavy Hitters in
the academic world and they consult with
companies uh quite often because
companies and Senior Executives some of
which may be joining us today look to
their thought leadership to help guide
the strategy of their
business uh thank you so much for taking
us through the steps and telling us a
little bit more about that about the
electives part here as we mentioned it
earlier as well the master classes with
Wen uh they are optional and they come
as a part of the program so you don't
have to pay anything extra for that uh
now moving on uh I think we have already
covered the world respected program
faculty which we have here basically
makes sure that simply learn is
delivering to what in standards and uh
let's move on to the real world example
projects you get to work on in this
particular program so iic as we can see
that there are so many projects you know
folks can take up and basically add up
to their portfolio specifically if the
as you told us that you know they're
coming from non-programming non
mathematic background and uh basically
these projects basically how do they
help uh you know when they are trying to
get out there you know get a job and
when they're preparing for these
interviews how do this projects help in
adding those Port basically projects to
their portfolio so can you tell us a
little bit about
that sure um and actually if you if you
don't mind just backing up one um I
think it's worth noting professors Kar
hassager and and sunny tomay actually
run uh Wharton's AI Center um so I I
think just another indicator of the
folks that we have teaching in the
program okay sorry rasher there was one
more plug for our faculty as you can see
um I sincerely appreciate their
involvement here now to these companies
and organizations I think what you're
going to find is someone that's maybe
aspirationally targeting career
advancement you're thinking about uh
moving up maybe within your own
organization or pivoting to something
new uh and we can go back to those cases
rash if you want I think it's one one
back uh you're going to have tangible
examples and information that you can
speak to Okay
um where you can call out cases you can
call out examples like you have studied
these things you are knowledgeable about
these things it's not some sort of
abstract notion right that you read in
an article you actually looked at
application and the subsequent impact of
that application and I think those sort
of opportunities start to feel real
right we start to actually flex and
exercise a muscle that is going to grow
stronger the more we do this the better
we get at it and that's I think one of
the deliberate reasons why we laid out
so many of these in the program is that
you get to start to flex and strengthen
that muscle and ultimately you'll be
better served for it as you move into
whatever's
next uh sure uh thank you so much for
answering that uh so we have talked
about the you know ai's role in business
and decision- making and we have talked
about uh basically the projects you can
add to your portfolio through this
program and we have talked about the
what and Advantage here you know taking
up this program how does won add to your
portfolio here and basically makes it
really amazing like you know how to have
like won online on your uh basically
portfolio when you're getting out there
and trying to transition your career
towards AI in business decision making
so uh you can see a quick p on your
screen here so uh are you interested in
enrolling for the AI for decision making
program with water online uh and for
this particular program uh for attending
this webinar as well we have a bonus
offer for you folks uh so you can Avail
that bonus offer uh by enrolling into
the program today so you can just
quickly select yes as an option here you
can see two quick options here yes and
no so you can share your interest
towards enrollment through this pool
here so as I was speaking I can see a
lot of interest interest towards
enrollment coming in so that's great I
can see a lot of folks basically are
aspiring to be a part of the program and
uh we might see a lot of your folks in
the upcoming goad so that's great so
I'll just give like 15 seconds more for
for the folks who are still basically
thinking about it and basically sharing
the response on the poll here meanwhile
uh we have gotten a lot of interesting
questions in the Q&A box and we'll be
taking those pretty soon so if you have
any questions about the program or the
career in general in AI for decision
making you can let us know in the Q&A
box and uh meanwhile uh maybe like I can
browse through the Q&A box here because
we've gotten a plenty of questions and
we'll take try to take as many as
possible in the in the next you know few
minutes of the time we
have and I saw a question from Hall uh
about the certificate branding uh we had
taken a quick peek at that a few slides
back it does include it's the Warton
brand that you'll see on that
certificate um okay some of
[Music]
the I'll just show the certificates once
as you can see in the screen perfect
thank
you
yeah so some of these yeah and hopefully
I'm just kind of catching up uh Brooke
about the content in the course we had
sort of that tiered approach where you
see it sort of cross over multiple
disciplines uh in verticals when it
comes to finance HR um Global Management
and you think about a a series of
pre-recorded videos readings
applications of what you learn and
ultimately the opportunity to sort of
like distill that that down and apply it
through the cases that we just mentioned
in addition to some of the uh master
classes that you'll get access to at
least once a month and that in in a lot
of cases I think is is a it's a key
aspect to the program because you
consider that that Professor is walking
in to the virtual classroom on a
particular day with all of you able to
talk about the news of the day what has
just happened what has just emerged in a
really Dynamic and fluid way uh in
addition to just talking about their
active research and Consulting work and
I think that is a real good opportunity
to start to take the core sort of
Evergreen fundamental learnings of the
program when a learning management
system and start to think kind of more
broadly about how that's impacting um
the events of right
now let's start any prerequisites for
the program not to my knowledge uh some
of these uh questions are sector
specific for the businesses in which
people work I would just offer with all
due respect to the things that I can
offer to all of you and the audience
today I would not be the right resource
to start to talk about the specifics of
how AI impacts your particular business
or organization I'm sure our faculty
would be much better suited um and
hopefully the curriculum itself can help
you find those applications too
individually so okay I think I covered
some of that um Brooke there's no
necessarily formal office hours that uh
with the faculty themselves but there
are sessions sort of facilitated early
on with an induction ceremony we bring
also more uh thought leadership to Bear
outside of Orton faculty and a kickoff
session that starts with every cohort
again another good opportunity to ask
questions and sort of apply learnings
this particular uh session I think we
wrap up whenever the Q&A is finished uh
let's see the class timings and the
duration they are and actually it's a
good question because we were talking
about this with the simply learned team
just this past week traditionally we've
done these on Saturdays in the morning
for the east coast of the United States
say 10:00 a.m. so IST time before
daylight savings puts us at 7:30 p.m. we
sort of did that intentionally to try to
get all of Europe all of Africa all the
way to uh our neighbors in Pakistan and
India that I know are joining us today
and inclusive of the early morning on
the west coast of the United States but
we've also started to entertain having
some of those on week nights uh here in
the east coast which would be say early
morning or mid morning for parts of
Europe Africa and uh Western Asia so the
classes themselves the master classes
spend typically at least 90 minutes if
not two hours in length and depending on
the robustness of the conversation and
the questions you know that can go on
for at least two hours if not longer and
let's see let's keep also Eric I think
folks have a lot of them have already
shared their interests towards the
enrollment with the program so that's
great we have got in a lot of aspiring
uh folks here who are going to join the
program uh meanwhile I can see uh most
of you have already shared their
responses on the poll here so I'll just
give five seconds more so quickly folks
uh just go and share your responses on
the poll here would you like to enroll
into the uh program for eii for decision
making with what online you can see a
quick on your screen here so I just give
like 10 seconds more so for you to
basically share your responses here and
also just to remind you there's a bonus
offer for attending this webinar here so
in case you want to Avail it I'll be
asking those those questions next
basically when do you plan to start so
and what the fee and the schedule we'll
be sharing that next so I think I'll
just quickly end the poll here because I
think most of the folks have already
shared their interest so 5 4 3 2 1 let
me quickly end the poll and thank you so
much uh for sharing your responses on
the poll here so moving on let me take
you through the enrollment steps here
there are three easy steps you need to
follow to enroll here uh so you need to
submit an application you can apply at
ask USS simple.net I'll be sharing that
email ID after I'm done uh with this SL
uh after that your application will be
going for review and based on the
application review you'll be getting
admissions off a letter call from
learning consultance from Simply learn
and you basically can also you know go
through much more detail with the in
case you have any questions about the
program and moving on to the program fee
and the schedule part uh so uh the
upcoming cohort for this one is 8th of
November and uh the program fee for us
candidates here
is
okay are folks still with
me because I lost audio and video too
all right let me know in the chat if you
can okay great Omar thank you I think
rash is coming back on
and she was going through some of the
mechanics she was just mentioning that
the next cohort starts November 8th I
think the program retails for
$3,000 um but I know the simply learn
team will be guiding folks through
potential um tuition benefits that been
made available for attendance
and I think that starts to Rashia how
are we doing uh awesome sorry sorry for
the technical issue from my no problem I
thought I had I had a I had the electric
company on my street earlier and I was
getting nervous it was me okay thank you
so much so as we were talking about the
fee part here so for Indian candidates
we have the fee of
135,000 INR including taxes and we also
have financing options available for as
low as
4,594 rupees uh per month uh for more
assistance you can always reach out to
us at ask us at simply. I'll share the
that email ID here I'll just quickly
share those uh details here even about
the program page Link in case uh as I
saw that you a lot of your folks are
joining from different different parts
of the world so if you want to check out
the program uh fee and the schedule for
your own uh basically region you can
check out this link I've shared about
for the program on the chat
here
sorry quickly share the program link
here on the chat you can check it out uh
for your own agent here and uh again
like so sorry sorry for the technical
issues we had earlier so again like so
I'll just quickly launch a poll on
basically for the folks who have already
shared their interest towards enrollment
into the won AI program uh how soon do
you plan to enroll in the won AI program
you can see four quick options here
again just to remind you for the folks
who have already shared interest which I
saw most of you who basically are
interested in enrolling to the program
uh these are four quick options here in
case basically you are still thinking
about it I would suggest
that you can take up the within 3 months
or within 6 months or more than 6 months
from now option because the bonus offer
you'll be getting to uh attending this
webinar you can Avail that even from
more than six months from now so uh I
would suggest like take up any of those
option which is more suitable for you
I'll keep up this poll alive for 10
seconds more because I can see folks
have already started sharing the
responses while I was speaking so you
folks are pretty quick so so okay and
meanwhile I think we have answered a lot
of those question questions uh in the
Q&A box here so
uh okay okay okay I can I think I'll
give five seconds more for the poll
here uh folks who are responding on chat
here you can let us know on the poll
here that will help us understand
because we miss a lot of messages we get
on chat here so I hope you understand
okay I think most of the folks have
already shared uh the their responses
for the when do they plan to enroll so
I'll just quickly end this poll in 5
seconds so 5 4 3 2 1 let me quickly end
the poll and once again like thank you
so much for sharing that with us so uh
Eric I think uh coming to the q& part I
think we have taken a lot of questions
right you have answered a lot of these
questions during the session itself uh
maybe let's browse through and see if we
have any uh relevant question you know
towards the program or AI in
general
yeah I think there's just a couple of
repeat questions I see still coming in
um and apologies if anybody thought this
program or this particular session today
would be geared more towards uh the
lessings themselves those are found
actually within the program so apologies
for any confusion if that happened um
the certificate uh I think they're
asking some of those are about this
particular session right and applying
that certificate RHA that sounds I I
think right if you don't mind just
clarifying that for folks again sure
sure yes you'll be getting a certificate
for attending this webinar and you'll be
receiving that post webinar email you
know with the recording link of the
session so you can expect that for that
you need to basically uh stay till the
end of the session we basically are
towards the end of the session uh so uh
before yeah before that I would love to
know that for folks who have already
shared their interest towards enrollment
into the program and also have let us
know basically when do you plan to
enroll so just a quick poll to
understand if you need any assistance in
enrolling into the AI for decision
making uh you know a program with what
and online so there are two quick
options there yes and no uh please do
let us know and
uh
okay as we scroll through the chat here
and the Q Anda I'm just just checking
out if we have anything
here
uh okay U I think Brooke has asked what
is the length of the course so it is of
three months duration you can just
complete it by giving like three to four
hours per week so I hope that answers
your
question any more questions about the
program in
general okay I think uh we have gotten
one question Eric I don't know if you
have taken this up I think this is
pretty recent I'll just put this down on
the chart for you because we have gotten
a lot of questions here so so this is
I've just put on this question on the
chart is this program suitable to a
person currently working as a machine
learning engineer I'm doing software
engineer
work I think it is if you are looking to
learn more about the impacts to business
and business
strategy if you're looking to take a
deeper dive into engineering and
software engineering work I would say
probably
not um also to the the question about
the Amazon box behind me I believe
that's part of my Halloween costume
fingers crossed that it fits thank you
for that
question okay awesome uh I think I can
see most of the folks have already
shared the responses for the poll here
so I'll quickly end the poll now and uh
we basically are towards the end of the
session so uh first of all uh would love
to thank Eric for taking the time out
and taking us to the program review for
what's online course for ni uh Eric
would like would you like to see
something through the folks here before
we end the
session I'd like to say thank you to to
you Rasha for hosting us today um and
for keeping us moving I also you know as
I said at the beginning of the session I
really appreciate everybody uh taking
some time out of your day-to-day to join
us I realize that all of you out there
are busy you're juggling a number of
different things and the fact that you
were able to carve out a little bit of
time to spend it with us we really
appreciate that um so so I hope you
found this informative and if you
consider this program further I wish you
good luck um and good luck frankly in
all that you do as you move forward uh
and it's been really nice to spend some
time with everybody
today uh thank you so much Eric I can
see responses coming in on chat here uh
so we'll be ending the session now you
can expect a post webinar survey uh on
your email and where you can put down
your full name for the webinar
certificate so thank you so much once
again folks for joining the session uh
we do a lot of these uh you know master
classes free master classes throughout
the month I've shared the link on the
chat here in case you want to check out
other webinars as well and once again
like thanks Eric for joining the session
and taking the time out thank you so
much everyone thank you we'll be ending
the session now take
care